reaktionen auf masken und berater
affären die csu verschärft die regeln
für mandatsträger ex-minister alfred
sauter gibt seine parteiämter ab vor dem
corona gipfel immer mehr länder sprechen
sich für notbremse und verschärfungen
bis nach ostern aus urlaub mit
einschränkungen deutsche touristen auf
mallorca lösen bei einheimischen
zwiespältige gefühle aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei heute am sonntag mit
norbert könig für den sportlern genannt
die csu wird gerade heftig
durchgerüttelt ein halbes jahr vor der
bundestagswahl
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt gegen
mehrere abgeordnete wegen korruption
ministerpräsident söder ergreift jetzt
die flucht nach vorn und verschärft die
regeln für mandatsträger ex
justizminister alfred sauter der wohl
auch viel geld bei einem masken deal
verdient hat legte heute seine ämter in
der csu nieder
alexander pohl der druck auf den
csu-chef steigt die partei kämpft um
ihre glaubwürdigkeit in der affäre um
den ehemaligen bayerischen
justizminister alfred sauter will markus
söder mit einem zehn-punkte-plan die
initiative zurückgewinnen alle
parlamentarier müssen über
nebentätigkeiten auskunft geben
sie müssen alle nebeneinkünfte
offenlegen und abgeordnete in
führungspositionen dürfen mit ihrer
nebentätigkeit kein geld verdienen
dies ist nicht ein zahnloser tiger
sondern wird ein scharfes schwert werden
wer sich nicht daran beteiligt dass sein
gutes recht aber dann wird der
parteivorstand von seinem recht gebrauch
machen
einspruch zu erheben gegen die
nominierungen vor ort und auch was die
liste auf der bundestagsliste begriff in
söders vorstellung ist die csu unter ihm
eine modernere partei geworden
die geschäfte eines alfred sauter ein
urgestein der partei für söder und seine
neue csu eine gefahr im märz 2020
entwirft sauters kanzlei einen vertrag
zwischen dem masken händler domotex und
dem bayerischen gesundheitsministerium
es geht um corona masken im wert von
über 14 millionen euro vermittler der
bundestags abgeordnete georg nüßlein
nach zdf informationen soll sauter für
seine tätigkeit einen millionenbetrag
erhalten haben
gegen ihn und nüßlein ermittelt die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft wegen des
anfangsverdachts der bestechlichkeit
sauter weigert sich weiter über die höhe
seines honorars auskunft zu geben
nachdem ihm die csu konsequenzen
angedroht hatte legte er alle
parteiämter nieder
ab heute lässt sauter auch seine
mitgliedschaft in der csu
landtagsfraktion
es ist ein erster schritt aus unserer
sicht reicht er aber tatsächlich noch
nicht über weitere maßnahmen etwa einen
ausschluss aus der fraktion will man in
der csu ab morgen beraten die frage nach
berlin was bedeutet so das durchgreifen
denn für die schwesterpartei cdu chef
und manager also in der cdu wird das gar
nicht so sehr als einseitiges
durchgreifen interpretiert sondern da
hören wir aus fraktions und
parteikreisen dass man dass er verstehen
möchte als fortsetzung der gemeinsame
bemühungen um schärfere
transparenzregeln und tatsächlich ist es
ja von markus söder auch eine reaktion
auf die eigenen vorfälle in den eigenen
csu rein aber man muss auch sagen unter
gewissen zugzwang gerät die cdu jetzt
doch da markus söder heute auch in der
pressekonferenz gesagt hat er ist bereit
über weitest gehende maßnahmen in sachen
transparenz zu reden und damit rückt er
die union ein stück näher an das an was
die spd schon gefordert hat nämlich die
offenlegung von nebeneinkünften ab dem
ersten cent es ist schwer vorstellbar
dass sich die cdu dagegen jetzt noch
groß werden wird vielen dank und energie
morgen tagt wieder der korona gipfel und
wie befürchtet liegt der bundesweite
durchschnitt der neu infektion mit 103,9
inzwischen über dem wert für den eine
notbremse vorgesehen ist
heute meldet das robert-koch-institut 13
1733 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages 2943 mehr als vergangenen sonntag
99 menschen starben in verbindung mit
coop 19
gleichzeitig wächst bei vielen die
ungeduld angesichts der einschränkungen
im alltag patricia wiedemeier so könnte
es bald schon wieder aussehen in den
städten zahlreiche länder sprechen sich
für eine verlängerung oder gar
verschärfung des schattens bis nach
ostern aus da das virus sich bedrohlich
ausbreitet deswegen ist meine dringende
empfehlung für montag keine weiteren
öffnung schritte eine konsequente
umsetzung der regelung zur sogenannten
notbremse und vorsicht
in den nächsten wochen doch der handel
hält das nicht mehr lange durch man
müsse die grundlagen für die maßnahmen
ändern zum beispiel die belegung der
intensivstation einbeziehen fordert der
städtetag brauchen einen neuen
orientierungswert von incidents von
belastungen der ids von der impfquote
bis zur sterberate muss das neu
eingestellt werden
morgen werden die ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten erneut mit der
kanzlerin beraten einen tag vor der
sitzung kommt von den drei nordländern
die forderung kontakt armen urlaub im
eigenen bundesland zuzulassen zitat nur
innerhalb des eigenen bundeslandes soll
urlaub in einrichtungen mit
selbstversorgung und eigenen sanitären
anlagen zum beispiel in einer
ferienwohnung oder ferienhaus in einem
campingwagen oder wohnmobil zulässig
sein
der urlaub auf mallorca ist gefährlich
dort ist schon die brasilianischen
mutante festgestellt worden und wir
sollten lieber vor ort bleiben in der
eigenen heimat und einen kleinen urlaub
ermöglichen als dass jetzt alle durch
die welt reisen in einem papier der spd
geführten länder wird zudem eine
quarantäne und tests pflicht für
reiserückkehrer aus dem ausland
gefordert unabhängig vom
infektionsgeschehen also auch für
mallorca urlauber wo die inzidenz
derzeit unter 30 liegt er seit einer
woche sind die balearen kein
risikogebiet mehr dass reisen dorthin
ist möglich ohne dass man bei der
rückkehr einen test machen oder in
quarantäne muss und so ist die nachfrage
groß
auch heute hat ein reisekonzerne
hunderte deutsche urlauber nach mallorca
geflogen
doch bei den einheimischen ist die
freude nicht ganz ungetrübt an
endlich wieder mallorca endlich wieder
urlaub die jungs aus karlsruhe planten
schon länger der pandemie zu entfliehen
für ein paar tage wenigstens die valoren
auf mallorca es offen
und dann hieß es sofort ok jungs buch um
ihr ticket ist eigentlich schade dass
der tourismus so in deutschland dann
eigentlich darunter leitet und man
eigentlich dann als deutsch dazu
gezwungen ist eigentlich woanders der
urlaub zu machen mallorca braucht die
rückkehr der deutschen urlauber dringend
fast alle jobs hängen direkt oder
indirekt an der tourismusbranche nach
monatelanger zwangspause gibt es für die
mallorquiner nun endlich wieder arbeit
am mittwoch wurde ich von meinem chef
angerufen und er hat mich gefragt ob ich
zurückkommen kann und ich bin einfach
superglücklich
doch in die freude mischen sich bedenken
um jeden preis soll verhindert werden
dass mit der zahl der feriengäste auch
die zahl der infektionen wieder steigt
die insel kann sich keine weitere corona
welle leisten und so gilt deine masken
pflicht und eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre
bars cafes restaurants dürfen nur bis 17
uhr gäste empfangen ihn der tourismus
auf mallorca kommt wieder ins rollen
doch sie lassen es langsam angehen
gerade mal fünf prozent der hotels sind
derzeit geöffnet
nach der demonstration gegen die korona
maßnahmen in kassel gibt es kritik an
der defensiven polizeistrategie bei dem
querdenker protest wurden massiv
auflagen missachtet die polizei setzte
die regeln jedoch kaum durch thüringer
polizisten sollen zu den teilweise
aggressiv gegen gegen demonstranten
vorgegangen seien
thüringens innenminister meyer kündigte
eine untersuchung an
ja und damit sind wir schon beim sport
und einem deutschen erfolg im tennis
arbeit ja alexander zverev darf mal
wieder feiern
landestypisch sonnen geschützt freut
sich der beste deutsche tennisspieler
über seinem 14
turniersieg auf der atp-tour im finale
von acapulco mexiko gegen stefano city
pass breite krempe breite brust der
sombrero des siegers auf dem kopf des
hamburgers alexander zverev vorne im
bild liegt im finale gegen den
topgesetzten griechen stefan auszieh
pass zunächst 1 zu 4 hinten
dank nerven starker aufholjagd in langen
grundlinienduellen triumphiert der 23
jährige auf dem hartplatz von acapulco
am ende 6 zu 4 und 7 zu 6 sein erster
turniersieg in diesem jahr
mainz 05 und hertha bsc punkten im
abstiegskampf der fußball bundesliga
die mainzer verbessern sich durch das 2
2 1 und hoffenheim auf platz 15 die
berliner stehen direkt davor in der
tabelle durch das klare 3 zu 0 gegen
bayer leverkusen
fabian rießle aus breitnau wird beim
weltcup finale der nordischen
kombinierer in klingenthal dritter beim
neunten saisonsieg des gesamt weltcup
gewinners johannes rieger aus norwegen
und es gibt noch andere deutsche erfolge
am letzten großen wenn das
sportwochenende bestes deutsches weltcup
ergebnis beim skicross finale im
schweizerischen weh so nahe stehen
gleich drei deutsche im endlauf florian
wilms man gewinnt vor dem franzosen idol
als dritter kommt tim roddick ins ziel
vierter wird cornell rinn sechs
fehlschüsse aber franziska preuß läuft
bei der windlotterie in östersund doch
noch auf platz drei im massenstartrennen
und
sichert sich auch den dritten platz im
gesamtweltcup erste heute die
norwegerinnen tante wollt das war es
kurz und knapp danke norbert und was
macht das wetter nächste woche nicht
viel anderes die sonne zeigt sich morgen
nur im nordosten sonst bleibt es meist
trüb gelegentlich wird es feucht an den
alpen schneit es leicht die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 1 grad
im allgäu und 11 grad in berlin
aber dann wird es im lauf der woche
deutlich wärmer ab mittwoch geht sogar
bis 17 grad auf das war es in kürze von
uns mehr hat es heute journal mit claus
kleber und drei viertel ziehen
wir wünschen noch einen schönen
sonntagabend sagen tschüss bis morgen 19
uhr und geben jetzt ab nach berlin zu
schicken der manager